if you watch pro wrestling you know Jim
Duggan he is a legend he won the first
ever Royal Rumble in WWE history back in
1988. so you watch him on TV you think
that man looks pretty tough but is he
really tough I mean it's kind of an act
right what is he really like well now we
know earlier this month Duggan was with
his wife at home in the country in South
Carolina they heard a man banging on the
door the man burst inside the Duggan's
home said he was going to try he was
trying to hide from other people or
trying to kill him
so Duggan grabbed the man and threw him
back out on the porch and then got his
44 magnum and waited until police
arrived kind of an amazing story an
American
defending his home on his own without
federal assistance Tim Duncan joins us
to go through what happened Jack
appreciate your coming on Jim thank you
so what did I don't know if I
characterized that exactly right tell us
what happened
Tucker thank you my pleasure to be here
yeah but pretty much you know we live
out in the country we're on a dirt road
I've got about 10 acres everything is
fenced in we got a big gate so we leave
the door open most of them dying to let
the dogs and the cats in and out you
know during the evening so I'm sitting
there watching TV all of a sudden the
pounding on the door I jump up as I get
to the door the doors burst open the sky
falls in because there's a step to get
into my house he falls in I switch back
to the old time days I'm like ah I
grabbed him I throw them out on the
front porch you know and I I spread
eagle spread eagle on the porch and I
reach in and of all the guns to have
inside I use it to scare off the coyotes
and foxes for my my ducks and chickens
is a 44 magnum I got the 44 magnum it's
a pretty intimidating gun and I got him
down on the ground it's spread eagle and
he's screaming help me help me they're
trying to kill me so now I'm thinking
well this is not a Holmen Invasion
because I I first checked the back door
to make sure nobody else was coming in
that was my first impression it was a
home invasion yeah so I saw nobody else
come in and I pushed him down he's
screaming other guys are coming to kill
him I can hear people out in the dirt
road yelling we're going to get you so I
had my wife turn off all the Christmas
lights you know where I'm back lit I'm
holding them down I got my gun I said
nobody knows we're up here just be quiet
and my wife God bless she's on the phone
with 9-1-1 almost at hysterics or her
blood pressure was way up and she said
send the fire department send the
ambulance send everybody so all the
Kershaw County Sheriff's Department they
were great they responded but I tell you
what Tucker is as quick as it happened
it wasn't quick enough people aren't
happy to see a cop until you need one
buddy and I'm standing there on the
porch with a gun in my hand two men out
there yelling I don't know who they are
I don't know if they have guns of what
this guy brought to my house so I'm
waiting for the police and I'm way when
I first saw those blue lights I was a
happy man
he must have been a little surprised
that he broke into your house of all
people's house did you ever get the
backstory who was this guy and who were
the other people
well it come to find out and our dirt
road there's only like five or six
houses the guy had a restraining order
against him for a young girl at the end
of the house or into the road excuse me
he broke into their house or I guess it
was her brother and Uncle I don't know
what the combination was but two men had
pistols they pistol whipped him chased
him down the road every house he went to
we pounded on the door help let me in
nobody led him in until he got to my
house our house he climbed over the
fence he lost his shoes broke into the
house thank goodness Tucker I didn't
have a gun when he first came through
because I I thought he was an invasion
he first named cool I went back to
wrestling ah I got him I threw him out
of the house you know and then then I
grabbed that big uh 44 magnum what are
the odds we stop stumbling to the home
of like a legendary pro wrestler
probably pretty low that small little
town in South Carolina too you know
that's one thing with wrestling you can
live anywhere long as you're near a
major airport so I use the Charlotte
Airport and we love living out in the
country we gotta the girls call it my
hobby Farm I got ducks and chickens dogs
and cats and so to have someone even
make it to the door was a shock but to
have somebody break through the door was
a whole different deal so for viewers
who aren't professional wrestlers no
history of it which is most
um what would you recommend if someone
breaks into your house
well the first thing you know that's a
fight or flight mode you go into I think
some people which would be the right
decision maybe to go to a safe room
maybe run to another house go to a
neighbor my first instinct was to attack
uh you got to do what you feel is
properly right but the first thing you
got to do is call the cops call the
police man because I tell you Tucker my
heart was pounding through my shirt I
got this guy spread eagle I hear people
yelling on this dark the road it was a
terrifying ordeal in way and I'm waiting
and waiting and waiting which probably
wasn't that long but all of a sudden you
see those blue lights flicker and it was
like the calvary was coming amazing
amazing and weirdly amusing and great
Jim Duggan thank you so much for that
story I appreciate it well you know
Tucker I'm old school wrestling before I
go and you might want to do one with me
let's go tough guy oh
USA USA
I can't pull it off but I love you you
can do it no I'm gonna do it in private
when no one's watching Jim Duggan say hi
to your dogs for us thank you thank you
buddy
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight